let's bring you some breaking news
coming out of iraq at least 12 police
officers have been killed in an attack
near the northern city of kirkuk
suspected isil fighters targeted a
vehicle checkpoint let's get more on
this
joins us from baghdad details now
emerging of that attack just bring us up
to speed on what we know happened
well
two separate attacks one in south of
kirkuk the other in mahmoud south of
mosul the first attack that happened
overnight it was a twin attack by isil
militants who first
engaged in military confrontations with
the checkpoint uh checkpoint uh
individuals uh the those belonging to
the federal police the iraqi federal
police uh and then they killed three of
the federal police individuals in the
first attack that happened overnight and
then they set up a kind of an ambush
when the backup came from the federal
police to that checkpoint
in the russia area south of kirkuk then
they exploited two explosive devices and
killed the rest so the number of dead is
12 federal police individuals three
injured and one
missing now eyewitnesses in the area say
that the the evacuation of the of the or
the retrieving of the bodies of the
casualties uh was conducted via
helicopters but
there was a night vision missing
equipment which made it difficult for
the federal police to retrieve
the bodies now the area in that area
why isil militants are moving freely in
that area remember that there is a lot
of marshlands it's
its geographical structure is difficult
and uh
isil militants have been uh
taking advantage of that geography of
that area to spread their attacks
launching multiple attacks targeting
federal police checkpoints and also
before that even targeting uh
power plants the other attack that
happened during the dawn this morning
early morning
in mahmoud in south of mosul isil
militants launched an attack on a
checkpoint
set up by the iraqi army and killed
three iraqi army individuals they have
been active in mahmoud area especially
in the areas between the control of the
federal
forces belonging to the iraqi government
and the areas
under control of the bhismarga forces
for the update thanks very much mahmoud
abdullah had there for us in baghdad